Although this is an incredibly
attractive chart, this is not what you
need to do to get a futures payout.
What's going on guys? Mr. Zinc here.
Today's video is going to be all about
data. Before we get into the data that I
use and have been using to get to my
futures payouts, I'm going to annotate
this chart real quick just so you can
see how simple it is to get to your
goals. You're getting in your own way.
You have too much on your chart, over
complicating everything in your head.
All you need to do is simplify down to
what you know. What I use in the first
three lines that you see on the chart
here is the initial balance breakout.
This is the first 60 minutes of market
open. And we're going to break that down
in the data showing the high or low as
well as the midpoint. Always using that
50 of the opening range. Price has a 97%
chance of breaking that high or low on
any given day. Again, we're going to go
and review that data. Along with the
initial balance breakout, I use my
previous day's 50, which in this case,
we're annotating Wednesday into
Thursday. Wednesday's low from 4:00 a.m.
to Wednesday's high from 7:30 or just
about that 8:00 p.m. close. And then we
use our London 50, which is 4 a.m.
any high made in 4 in between the time
frame of 4 a.m. and whatever the open
is, 9:15, 9:30. So, our high looks like
it was about 7:30 this morning. And then
our low should be about 5:00 a.m., 4:30,
4:45, somewhere in that range. That's
our London 50.
Going into the data, we're going to
cover the initial balance. And this is
all brought to you from Edgeville. I'm
going to drop the link to them into the
description. They do have a 7-day free
trial right now. QQQ. And then I go to
and this is what I'm charting on Q's and
then I trade on MNQ on top tradeify
whatever project X platform I'm using at
the time. So we go over to Edgeville, we
use Q's, we go to
all reports and then we go to the
initial balance breakout report. What
this is going to give us is the data for
any initial balance break over the past
six months. 93 out of 125 days you will
have a single break. meaning that one of
the high or lows will get broken and
price will not reverse and go back to
that high or low.
24% of the time you have price break
both of those levels. So you'll have the
low break for today's example and then
let's say we went all the way back up
towards the high. And then 1.6% of the
time or the better way to use this is
98.4% of the time you're going to have
price break out of either the high or
low of that range. Only 1.6 6 or 2 out
of 125 days price stayed within that
range that was established within the
first 60 minutes. And you can see how
simple this trading strategy is, how
simple the model is. You just have to
use data. You have to continue to use
data that tells you are you successful?
Are you not successful? In what areas
are you failing? What areas are you
succeeding? You want to pursue those
areas that you're succeeding. The London
50 model, we made those adjustments. And
I'll drop the link to those adjustments
right here. Made adjustments to the
London 50. We no longer take it on the
opening candle. We no longer use
previous days 50 for bias and anything
after three taps on either the London 50
or the previous days 50 no longer valid.
Along with the initial balance range and
the data that comes with the initial
balance, I also go and use the initial
balance rejection as I just covered. It
tells you when either the low or the
high of that initial balance is formed.
These are the chances that you have to
go and break either the high or the low.
For today's example, since we formed the
high first, the wick high was made
pretty much right at open and then we
went and made the low at about 10:00
10:15.
Our chance of breaking the low is 58%.
Not ideal. Typically, what I like to see
are these 92% statistics, but obviously
we didn't form the low today first. The
initial bounce still worked.
It was below 50% of the initial bounce
range. I entered about 61026 on Q's. It
was only a 20 point move to the
downside. Pretty choppy today.
Along with that initial bounce
rejection, I go over to the screener on
Edgeville and I use the opening candle
continuation, initial bounce standard,
initial balance rejection and then the
opening range breakout. in these four
combinations.
Uh it shows you Apple, Amazon,
Microsoft, Meta, Nvidia, Tesla, SPY Q's.
Are they bearish? Are they bullish? Why?
And then it gives you an overall bias
for the day. I briefly look at this
around 10:15 and this guides me towards
just adding confluence if I want to take
longs or if I want to take shorts.
for MNQ.
I chart Q's and then I go and trade on
MNQ. Typically do five lots of MNQ. As
you can see right here, I'm already
locked out for the day because it was
again pretty choppy. Didn't want to risk
anything. Glad I did. We had the initial
balance break. We have done absolutely
nothing since. The next thing that I
want to add on the initial balance, I'll
go back to cues, go to initial balance
report, and we're going to go down to
the buy levels. And what this tells us
is what are the chances that we go and
proceed to these standard deviations.
Standard deviations are just the size of
the initial balance. Half a standard
deviation is half the initial balance.
Also 50%.
One standard deviation, one initial
balance. So on and so forth. Our percent
chances of proceeding further past the
initial balance pretty low. 50 5050 and
then 33.3%.
That's us going to half a standard
deviation, one standard deviation, 1.5,
two. This is also just for Thursday.
We've only had six total breaks on
Thursday. Three out of six of those have
happened to hit 1.5, 1, and 0.5. What I
like to use is I just like to use all
days. And then I go down and I'll also
tag all of these days, Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday. Save that.
And this gives you a better read. These
are the more accurate levels that I have
seen I've seen personally not data um
that I've kind of collected dayto day.
We only have a one in three chance of
going to half a standard deviation up or
down. We have a one in five chance of
going to one. We have a one in about 20
chance of going to 1.5 on either side.
What that tells me is that once the
initial balance is broken, and this is
also why I've been getting most of my
trading done prior to 10:30,
once the initial balance is broken, you
have a very slim chance of going to 0.5
or even one standard deviation. So, why
would I want to trade the chop that's
between the bottom of that standard
deviation and 0.5 or one? There's not
really much of a reason. Now, obviously,
there's news that's going to come out.
Sometimes we have FOMC at two. Sometimes
it's going to spike down to one 1.5, but
it's pretty low percent chance.
Another reason that I'm locked out today
is because we have one in three chance
of going down to 0.5. We happen to hit
1.5.
We also, if we just go to the QQQ
initial balance report itself, the
percent chance of us reversing and going
back up is only 24%.
doesn't really make much sense if we're
pursuing a 24% statistic to the upside
or if we're pursuing a
30% chance to the downside. Doesn't add
up. There's no reason for us to take a
valid entry on that because they're
pretty poor data points to be honest.
So, I'm happy with my trade at 10:30.
Yes, I only made $79 today. I did just
take that max payout yesterday. There's
no reason for me to pursue the rest of
the day. I'll go out, make a YouTube
video, play some video games, work a
little bit on the side, whatever it
whatever I want to do for the day, I'll
go and do that. There's no reason in me
staring at the charts knowing that data
is telling us we don't really have that
significant of a chance of going down or
up. We're just going to chop for the
rest of the day, which is exactly what
we're doing right now. We're pretty much
just making engulfing candles, pivoting
after a move to the upside or downside.
not much of a reason to pursue the rest
of the trading day. And this is back
tested not by myself but by Edgeful. And
you can go to six months or you can go
to five years. If I go to five years,
it's going to take a minute to load
here. It should be about the same
statistic. I'm just looking on cues for
the initial balance report. And this is
going to go all the way back to 2020
once it loads. This is going to be maybe
a couple more seconds here, but I do
this every single day at open. As you
can see, yesterday we had the initial
bounce high break. Previous day, we had
the initial bounce low. We had the
initial bounce low break. This one
happened to be a double break. But after
we took the low at 10:30 on Monday, I
was all done. There's no reason for me
to chase a 24% statistic to going to the
upside. Have a double break. I just tip
my hat to it. Move on to the following
trading day. This is back tested for
five years now. 953 out of the past
1,254
days. 76% of the time we've had a single
break. 21% of the time a double break.
And only 2.6% of the time, 33 out of the
past 1,200 days price stayed within that
initial balance.
And this is data back trading. There's
no emotions associated with it. There's
no reason for me to overlever into
positions. I take the same trade every
single day. We have a reaction at
London50. Great. We have a reaction at
previous days 50. Even better. If not, I
wait for the initial balance. Okay,
we're trading towards the downside of
that initial balance. I'm going to take
5 M and Q. I'll have $200 profit or I'll
have a $200 loss and I'll move on to the
next trading day.
London 50 adds confluence to those
levels as well as adding size. So if we
have the initial balance report and this
is just a hypothetical for today. Let's
say we are trading towards the high of
that initial balance. Price came down
retested London 50. Okay, I'm going to
enter five MNQ at London 50. We are also
targeting the initial balance high along
with London high. So I'm going to add
another five MNQ. Now I'm in for 10.
Okay, let's say that we also had an
opening candle continuation showing that
we have a 78% chance of closing green on
the day. I'm going to add another 5 M
andQ to that. So, that one trade with
extra added confluence to it, I'm now in
for 15 M andq, that's where those big
profit days come from.
Other than that, it's really just 5 M
and Q, 200 bucks, $300 profit days.
Those stack up a lot faster than you
think. Make sure that you're using some
kind of data or back testing your own
strategy. In this case, I love using
Edgeful. Again, I'm going to drop the
link to them in the description of this
video. That's just a quick review of how
I've been trading, how I just took a max
payout from Topep yesterday. Should
hopefully be in the bank sometime today.
Also just took a $7,500 payout from
Tradeify. All from hitting $2 to $500
days. Yesterday, I I went a little
heavy. Got 1,500 bucks on the initial
balance.
Steady steady gains. No emotions
associated with it. Just playing the
data.
Again, check the link in the
description. They have a 7-day free
trial going on right now. Hope you guys
enjoyed this quick little video. Peace
out.